[Music]
congratulations to each of you on
winning the contest and welcome to
Fantasy Island so what's your fantasy
the island hailers eats fantasy
specifically to the guests your life is
about to change forever
how the island does what dice is a
mystery to brought her back to life so
what's your fantasy revenge on a
childhood bully the most popular girl in
school was my tormentor let's have some
fun oh my god that's really hurt
this is not what I meant the island is
twisting our fantasies they were brought
here to be aware of something else
[Applause]
clothes organics six of our northern
cities have fallen in a coordinated
attack their leader fights alongside of
which
crush these murderers your majesty every
family must contribute one map to fight
your war hero you've already made many
great sacrifices
my father cannot fight so I will take
his place the northern invaders will
kill her if I expose her power all
people will kill her when we take the
Imperial City I will take revenge for my
father what is your name soldier
watch it commander sono cordial you will
now take the oath of the warrior
wait
[Music]
died attempting to be something you're
not
yet here I stand proof that there is a
place for people like us
a girl threatens our plants
a warrior
[Applause]
[Music]
we got there oh it's just my wife Emma
it's my son Charlie joy while at last
while last nothing happier than the wife
of a new detective it was cool man she's
different you know my wife woman 600
Tuesdays and ain't worth three Saturday
nights how much money you got how many
problems you got a lot how many people
detective banks in route
whoever did this has another motive
[Music]
the targeting cops
this shit's gonna go sideways fast
somes out there pono stress
you want to play games [ __ ]
you don't know everything about me
The Avengers weren't my first family
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
new your Ronnie we got some kind of fire
we got units headed out there now don't
know why he came all the way up here he
won't survive you know my dad told me
last night he said that you got a full
ride to Kansas we just quit why my
father didn't like me very much
and someone told him I was good at
basketball he paid a lot more attention
to me and I realized it wasn't me that
he loved it was what I could do wasn't a
lot of time hurting myself trying to
hurt my father I never pick up the
basketball game
[Music]
they need a new coach Jack you're the
first person I thought of
team any good no in fact the last time
we made the playoffs back when you were
playing this whole team ten kids won't
know why they're leaving you open it's
because I don't think you could hit the
ocean from the beach heard you're
coaching basketball just my mind off of
those things
I understand you're trying to motivate
the team but we have a code of conduct
[Applause]
like this is not as bad as record we
have to trust each other we have to have
faith
I just want you to be happy again but
you kind of want it to
don't underestimate the impact you can
have on
you got this no just not I'm gonna hear
your voice yes or no yes
nervous I get it truth is the more
talented than you probably a better
coach but I promise you they are not a
better team they haven't been through
what we've been through they don't know
adverse it looks like to get knocked
down half to get back up again
is the fight
we can't change the past Jack what we
can do is choose how we move forward my
dad believed in you I'm not gonna make
the same mistake you know what happens
to you if you don't deal with this I
have everything I need to have them
court-martialed and dishonorably
discharged
once a generation the finest warriors
must do battle to decide the fate of
their realm I shameful welcome you to
Mortal Kombat
[Applause]
if Shao Kahn wins this tournament from
birth as you know it will cease to exist
let Mortal Kombat begin I will win this
tournament let's see what you've got
what is it you want
to seek my revenge
[Music]
[Music]
goro
mission mortal kombat legends scorpions
revenge
on digital and blu-ray commercials in
this game are really expensive spongebob
it's just the pregame yeah 26 seconds to
tell me everything
let's go do I smell a road trip there
could be my breath the Spongebob movie
sponge on the run that was money
whispering are you looking at violent
market yep
our sister died right for your class
project you must report on two or more
wonders of Indiana can't we choose our
partners you're my geography class this
teacher wants us to do this project with
a partner I just don't want to do it
well maybe it's time to get back out
there what do you want from me I think
it would be good for you to get out
maybe I don't want to get out it might
end up loving you no I won't to wanders
that's all serious question what are you
most afraid of being ordinary so don't
be ordinary what's going on with you you
just seem like goofy what are you
looking at some kid on my lawn you're
all the colors in one at full brightness
you know people call you the freak right
sometimes I get into these dark moods
did you look into that support group I
told you to check out I want you to
think about it and do things that remind
me that I'm in control
people don't like messy we're different
you know that was kind of dangerous no
he's not a texter him for the past
couple days and he hasn't responded
he's not easy
just gets in this mood sometimes there
you go you just appear tell me something
real about you I just get a little lost
sometimes people don't like messy right
[Music]
sorry my phone died pilot inside finch
go home
you think this whole thing is an act my
port spear I keep messing things up I
don't know how to not do them
there are bright places and in dark
times
you can be that bright place
[Music]
I read your paper it contains some
exceptional science my instinct is that
there is another element you think you
found an undiscovered element science is
changing and the very people who are
running science believed the world was
flat leave my laboratory and my science
doesn't speak for itself then you have
greatly misunderstood it I'm going to
prove them wrong we all saw that atoms
were finite and stable well some of them
are not I have called this radioactivity
no discovery could cure cancer
you change the world our works been
nominated for the Nobel Prize the
commendation only mentions my name
they stole my brilliant I've dare you
take their applause this is bigger than
both like just wants to do good science
do those that say that radium is making
them sick
the question can be raised where the
mankind benefits from knowing the
secrets of nature
I have been haunted my entire life
trying to understand the impossible
this is my fight and I will win it
[Applause]
when it comes to speed there's only one
name I've studied the best spinners his
legendary I raced the fastest in the
world
he makes us all let's left I'm wild but
he's on another level that dude he knows
it's all about the Rings he turns on the
burners good luck
he's just a blur out there what's this
for again what's this for against this
Morgan what's this for again great
question I have no idea but please
McCaffrey go on about how amazing I am
what am i doing
now that's what I call good cop bad cop
left herself open
[Music]
you